So in a moment,
we'll address how you estimate the value
of that company that
generates $1 per year.
In other words,
that dollar bill machine.
Before we dig into that,
let's spend a moment considering why does
it matter how much a company is worth?
This course is about buying and selling
stocks, so we're going to look at why
company value matters with regard
to buying and selling stocks.
Of course, we want to buy a stock
when the price is too low and
we want to sell it when it's too high.
In general, the value of
a company goes up monotonically.
In other words,
it is always increasing over time.
Let's assume for a moment,
this is the true value of that company.
We'll address in a little bit what true
means, but let's assume for the moment
that we have some understanding of the
underlying real value of that company.
Now that true value is distinct and
different from the value
estimated by the market.
In other words, what price
the stock market says, it's worth?
So on one particular day, maybe
the price is higher than the true value.
On some other day, maybe it's lower and
on some other day, it's the same.
Very many trading strategies,
which is what this course is about,
focus on identifying
situations where the current
stock price is different
from the true value.
So in other words,
if the stock price goes up a lot, but
we know the actual company is
only worth a certain amount.
When it goes up high,
that might be a selling opportunity.
In other words,
if we see the price up here and
we know the true value of
the company is down here, sell it.
And similarly, if we see the price
really low compared to what the company
is worth, that could represent
a buying opportunity.
There are many, many ways that we can
estimate the true value of a company.
We're going to touch on a few
of them in this lesson.
One is intrinsic value,
this is based on the value of
the company as estimated
by future dividends.
In other words,
companies pay many companies not all,
pay each year or
each quarter a dividend.
So it's a cash payment,
if you own a share of stock,
you get a certain amount of dividend.
For instance, for Apple this year,
it's about $2 per year.
So intrinsic value is based on,
if we own one share of stock, we're
going to get some amount of dividends
accumulated over all of the future.
What's the value of
the company based on that?
Another is book value, which is based
on the assets that the company owns.
So in other words,
we add up the value of all
the factories that they own and so on.
Finally is market cap.
This is based on the value of
the stock on the market and
how many shares are outstanding.
So in other words,
this relates to what is the market
think the company is worth?
This relates to what's the value
of the sum of the assets?
And this one relates to, well,
if I own a share of stock,
how much money am I going to
get over the future?
And what's that worth overall
in the future going forward?